It had something gotta.
Find something though,
right?
You got to find a struggle.
It's very important to have a struggle
to have something you got to accomplish
because you can already.
Oh Shit.
There's a little bit of that.
What's going on,
man?
How do I turn the headphones over there?
Which one is it?
Jeremy.
Chuck.
Chuck,
Oh,
he's in my ears would live.
It's crazy how we looked at each other
when we walked in.
I know it is going to embrace what we
did,
man.
I want to lean into you.
We added,
Huh?
It's been a long time,
man.
Man.
What's up now?
Where do you go now?
I don't know.
Just try to stay alive and keep moving.
No,
you're doing it.
I remember who's asking you.
You're going to work one day.
Who's asked you just going to put one
day.
Stand up.
You've called out.
Somebody called out a motherfucker.
Just got to get into that.
We get into crates,
crates.
It was crazy when when we was doing
standup,
like it was like.
It was like gunslingers.
What happened with her?
Nothing.
You called them out though.
Well,
that was a bad situation.
We had a.
He was stealing.
Everybody's bringing up the wrong shit.
No,
no,
it's okay.
Okay.
Because I thought it was getting to be
nice about getting.
No,
no,
no.
You got to bring it a wrong.
Jamie Foxx,
whatever the terrain.
We were just talking about off,
off,
off mic.
About how,
how would we would've been in jail?
It had there been social media back when
is coming up.
We'd have life.
You have double life.
I'd be looking at you and myself.
Then you had to kill colors when we were
talking about everybody that came up in
the sixties or seventies.
The eighties,
the nineties.
Everyone before social media though.
Wild lives they lead.
You can't do that anymore.
I can't do it.
And what,
what this comes as you came for all
y'all just tuning in.
We'll be talking about like,
you know Chris Brown.
I'll see Chris Brown.
He'll come by my house and he'll,
he'll,
he'll just sit there and go like,
what the fuck,
you know?
And I said,
listen,
you're just too talented for for one
cats like him and Justin Bieber who've
been,
who've been blessed with extra.
They look good.
They can fight.
They,
they're athletic and they sing,
they dance.
They could dance.
The first time I met Chris Brown,
this is crazy.
I'm throwing a party in Miami and it's
me and call them feral Eddie Murphy.
Eddie Murphy who was still in it this
year is back to 2005 maybe,
I think.
Yeah,
2005 and a.
So I'm hosting a party in Miami.
The crowd's going crazy,
but in the down like not in the VIP is
some kids dancing.
I'm like,
who the fuck ain't dancing,
you know,
and all this shit.
And so my dj,
Dj Gary,
he goes,
Yo man,
that's a new kid.
Chris Brown,
Yo,
he bought to be the next one.
I said,
yeah,
but he thinks he dance because you know,
I know how to dance.
I'll go fuck him up.
You know what I'm saying?
This young man,
I going to know who I am.
I'll come down and fuck him up.
And it was like Fox,
okay,
so I'll go down there now,
you know,
it's sort of my time.
And so everybody's following me.
I'm about to go battle whoever this kid
is.
So I said,
yeah bro,
you think you can dance.
I did like some kind of bullshit.
Listen to me,
we're all,
we're all jammed together,
right?
He doesn't do a move.
You know what he does?
He does a back flip.
But the way he did the back flip and
he's six [inaudible] two,
he standing in the middle of the crowd.
He jumped over the crowd,
did the back flip up here and came
straight down and said,
what's up?
I said,
motherfucker,
I'm going to leave you the fuck.
Like I don't know what the fuck that,
that's some avengers shit.
And I just remember I said that dude,
when he get on and then he gets on,
but then social media catches on and
then it's just hard.
It's hard.
It's hard to live.
Uh,
when you're,
when you're social media,
and I tell them all the time,
you have this social media sort of makes
you color inside the lines or try to.
I'll try to.
Yeah.
Or like this.
It makes you took your artistry and
sometimes a little bit.
Does that make sense?
You're crazy and tuck it crazy and you
tuck your artistry and like,
I didn't know what a mean,
wasn't,
you know,
Shit,
I'm a fucking.
I was just catching on the mindspace and
shit.
She shifted.
So My,
my daughter sends me a picture of
Rihanna,
right?
Going to the met ball and by the time I
got the picture,
whatever happened,
the picture was Rihanna and in this
yellow dress and I hit my daughter.
I said,
I love the dress is amazing.
I don't understand the pizza that's in
it,
but man,
you know,
maybe that's a,
she's giving a nod to Italy and maybe
she got the dress for him.
And She's like,
no dad,
that's a meme.
I said,
well that's a meme.
what do you mean?
She says,
no,
there's actually not a pizza in the
dress.
Somebody crafted or fixed there,
they made it look like it's pizza
because Oh,
because it's trailing behind her and so
me,
I'm thinking,
well,
what the fuck is the mean?
It's just know that that's what I said.
So this girl worked her whole fucking
night to get this dress to go to the met
ball,
which is you're supposed to be,
you know,
out the box and somebody puts a pizza on
it and that's all you see is a pizza.
I said,
how do you compete with that?
How could you be Michael Jordan and kids
run up to you and say you're the cry
baby face man.
That's not a crime in it hasn't been the
best thing on the Internet.
It's one of the best things about the
ads because being able to make funny.
It's the best thing,
but watch this.
So once it sticks,
that's what I'm saying.
Once it sticks,
sticks Michael Jordan to somebody under
the age of 18,
he the cry baby face man.
Hey Man.
Hey in.
And then you know how you know how fans
do.
Men Cry Right quick.
Let me get you cry.
It's so true.
Yeah,
man,
it's so stuff.
Well,
we were talking about Jon Jones.
Jon Jones fight this weekend.
John Jones is a wild motherfucker and
that's why he's the greatest light
heavyweight of all time because he's.
So.
It's part of what you have to have it.
We've talking about.
Go be with Mike Tyson,
Mike Tyson,
back in the day.
You couldn't.
That's why when people say like,
why does Mike Tyson,
he first of all,
he's a fighter.
He's not a tennis player,
but Mike was a wild boy and to hang out
with him you could understand like he
was the biggest person on the planet and
he had the demons,
you know what I'm saying?
And.
But he's fun too because because you see
them in a club and he sees,
he sees some girls.
How you doing?
You like bmws and girls?
Like what do you like?
BMW,
like cars,
like bmws and crazy.
He'd take the girls out and go get a
BMW.
I mean he was at crazy.
You know what I'm saying?
C'Mon,
c'mon.
Let's look at the bar.
And we open up the BMW dealership.
But he was wild,
but I say just like,
how are we saying here?
You can't have that type of talent in
that area and not have this.
Jon Jones can't.
You can't.
You can't drink milk and it almost
killed somebody.
You know what I'm saying?
You can't.
You don't let me get that homogenized.
No,
you can't.
Yeah.
There's gotta be something about you.
The tighter control and impulsive,
wild,
dangerous,
and that's what makes him so great.
Everybody.
You even talked about,
even looking at people on your wall,
you look at Hendrix,
you look at Elvis,
they have to have something because
that's God fucking lose.
God's going to give you something
incredible,
but he's also going to give you
something to anchor that because I
believe this is what I believe in and
you tell me if you believe this.
I believe in the yen and the Yang of
everything.
Meaning like when there's absolute light
that has to be absolute darkness to
balance it out.
And that's what everything that we do.
It's sorta like we're not gonna.
Get Away with anything like anything
that happens to you in life.
You have to pay for it,
like it's like the grocery store.
Okay.
I got the career,
got gotta pay for that.
Okay.
I got the money.
Boom.
Okay,
I got to pay for that.
Then here come the family boot.
Yeah,
I need that money.
You fucking way.
I'm going,
I'm going.
I'm a real release the story about you.
So it's all of these different things
that you got to pay for and that's why
you see these guys like that.
Because like I said,
talking to Justin Bieber,
you know,
with everything I said,
some of this shit is supposed to happen
to you.
It has to.
He can't otherwise.
The think of the success that kids had
at 20 years old.
It's impossible.
I was just reading some shit about him
canceling his tour because he just said
too much work.
I mean he's just going crazy I guess,
but he's made $93,000,000
is here like Jesus Christ fucking 20.
Yeah.
And for us we like shit because you
know,
I ain't fuck,
I'm going to take that $90 million.
I'm going to go do a million,
but we can't be in his mind and we can
see how it is he grew up that way.
He grew up that way.
Never had a normal life and you don't
expect like I,
I,
like I always tell kids who want to be
in this business to please wait.
Like even with my kids,
just wait,
wait until you're like,
wait you to understand like I was able
to be grown and and have some grown shit
happened to me and just regular life
should happen.
So then when this happened,
I still have a point of reference to get
back to because you know,
like I know you've interviewed
everybody.
This business affects you in such a way
where you see one person one day,
I won't say the comedian's name,
but I remember a comedian back in the
day did like half of an hbo or whatever,
and then the next week I saw him.
He had 12 body guards and they were
pushing me back.
Then I was like,
what the fuck man?
Yo Man,
Yo now,
right now it just got crazy.
It got crazy and so they get crazy cars
and I see I out,
I won't say the names,
but there've been a couple of guys I
never get this one dude hit and I went
up to try to say something to him and
and for some reason he had a white suit
on.
We went to a club,
fuck this.
He had this white suit on and he's big
shades and I went to talk to him and he
said,
not right now,
man,
I'm rich.
He said that to everybody right now.
They got rich.
Let me be rich and famous right now.
I don't want to hear your pitch,
Jim,
something you think you could get away.
And I was like,
as he said it,
I had to sort of like,
okay,
I get that.
But that's,
you know,
that's what happens when you got to be
careful that tide goes in and it goes
out and people come up and they
remember.
They remember and remember when you
fucked with them and we've seen and
we've seen them,
but,
but being a comedian,
we get,
we get a chance to sit in a different
seat because we sort of are our jobs or
our observational,
you know what I'm saying?
We still have our own demons,
but it's.
It's just different.
You also get humbled a lot as a
comedian.
Yeah.
You got to get those jokes.
You're performing in front of a live
audience.
It's all live.
It's gotta work and it doesn't work.
Shit.
You got to go back to the drawing board
and it's got to assess.
Actors don't get a lot of that.
That's one of the reasons why they're
kind of shaky.
More shaky.
Yeah,
right.
Don't get a lot of that testing it live
in front of people.
That humility that comes with that you
don't and and it's in.
It's tough.
I was talking to her act,
another actor,
and it's tough because see,
I'm a comic who became an actor,
so I'm cheating.
You know what I'm saying?
I can go do this and I can go.
I'm going to be in St Louis tomorrow,
you know some jokes so I can,
you know,
I gotta get.
I can get my thing off.
But just actors,
it's tough when you figured out a way to
balance three careers,
you can sing too.
I mean you could do anything.
You're a weird guy in that way.
You got a lot of weird talent yourself.
He's talking about Justin Bieber and
Chris Brown.
You've got some weird ability to shift
to it.
Not only him,
but I've been fortunate in the fact that
now things have up like,
you know,
back in the day,
like you could only do one thing.
One thing I will never forget,
Keenan Ivory Wayans told me,
he said,
Yo,
what's with the singing shit?
You motherfucker,
I can't see you trying to sing and shit
or I would try to sing.
Can you see them?
No,
this is real.
And grow back.
Oh Jamie,
stop youtube.
Funny in the face.
Face is too funny.
I see one is singing to me.
You finally stopped.
So I was like,
fuck,
maybe I never seen.
You know.
So I was doing,
of course the stand up,
you know,
doing the one the shit and then it
wasn't until literally I was throwing
these parties at my crib and I would
always throw parties for like musical
guys,
you know,
so I threw a party for puff,
puff comes and big party,
it's like 2000 puffers there and it's
all about him and I'll never forget he
got mad at me a little bit because I
would follow him and I would,
I would actually follow him with,
with a,
with a camera because at that time,
at that time Paul was the biggest guy in
the world,
you know,
you couldn't even get in this party.
So the way we're getting this party,
I show up with a camera,
like your pump,
you need to document,
document the shit can turn around.
What's up playboy?
I said,
yeah,
let me get that.
Ain't nobody getting this and that.
And it wasn't back in the day with,
you know,
with the camera phone,
I had the big fucking cannon that you
put on your shoulder and the light and
the shit.
I said,
let me change the battery,
let me get all this shit.
Right.
So at one point I told him we were
actually in Philly and he was throwing a
party and he said,
Yo,
playboy,
this party is a million and a half
dollars.
I said,
like,
he said,
it costs a million and a half dollars to
throw this party.
I said,
Oh my God,
I love it.
The party is amazing.
Yes,
the mayor is here and everything.
I said,
but that's too much money.
you come to my place in La,
I'll throw you a party for $400 bucks
that will rival this party.
And he got a little mad because,
you know,
he was like,
Yo know I'm known for this shit.
Don't front.
I said,
I'm not,
I respect you.
I said,
but la,
I just know how to get around.
So he gets to La and he calls me early
in the morning,
you'll play but make that shit happens,
etc.
I said,
cool.
I'll go in on my phones and by 12:00
at my small house in tarzana and god
bless my neighbors that lived there.
I'm no longer there.
I know they wanted me to get out of it
because that was too much.
But the parties fevered pitch and I
invited the right people,
you know the right girls were beautiful
but not too tight.
Not too,
you know,
just everything was great.
The guys wouldn't know haters because la
could man,
fuck them,
fuck them because no one in that it was
the right guys and he shows up and when
he shows up,
he goes,
that's the girl on that tv show.
Oh,
that's the gIrl in the movie.
I said,
yeah,
you're with friends.
It's like we were all hanging out here.
So it's like,
you know,
it's all good and that's the cookie.
I said,
yeah,
yeah.
I said,
but look at the party.
look over there on the table.
I got Kentucky fried chicken,
but I put it into a nice plates.
I got coca cola,
but it's just in a picture.
I said,
we're at 280 bucks right now and
counting I won't go 400.
And he had the most incredible time.
Right?
But at that party was on musical people
and I did it for reason at that party.
Missy elliot,
of course,
she had her room.
Everybody's going crazy with missy
elliot.
I'm going into my garage and there's two
guys,
a little guy like this and a tall guy.
The little guy goes,
yo,
it's like this all the time,
be.
I said,
yeah,
who are you?
He said,
oh,
we didn't have to.
My name is fred.
I said,
yeah man,
I heard you.
That's how long ago this was.
Wow.
So he's like,
can I just go and have a great time?
Uh,
there was another guy standing on the
wall,
green jacket,
like a green little jumpsuit.
Nobody's talking to him.
Guess who was who?
Jay z.
Nobody
knew.
I said,
what's up man?
Great party.
So crazy.
No one knows.
But,
and now the way I got into the music,
however,
is that all these different parties was
going on and I would have like different
musical people leave me music in my
little studio that I built.
I went and got this great studio built
in the back of my house.
and so one day incomes as kid backpack
on jaws busted.
Who is it?
Who kanye.
Oh,
his jaw was busted from my car accident,
right.
Kanye and walks in and I said,
who's that?
They said,
well,
that said,
new motherfuck kanye man.
He bout to beat the shit.
I said,
what do you do?
Well,
he produced,
but he also wraps.
I said,
well,
anybody come to my house?
They got to perform.
So I said,
yo man.
They say,
you know,
you wrap it.
He wrapped the most incredible free.
I don't know if it was free.
It was incorrect.
I said,
I don't know why you aren't famous.
He did it with a broken jaw.
He had a little little jobs,
a little swollen.
I don't think it was broken,
but it was a little swollen because it
wasn't too long after that accident that
he had.
Right.
And then he goes,
ah,
I,
I got a song that dad,
you will,
you will be good on a song.
I know you could kill it.
I was like,
man,
so
goofy face
from a living calisa yeah.
I said,
oh shit.
Cool.
So we go in the back.
One of the students got studio in the
bag.
So he sings.
He says,
the song's going to go.
She say she wants some marvin gaye,
some luther vandross.
So I said,
I got it.
She said she wants a mom being good.
He's like,
what are you doing?
I said,
well,
I got to put them,
you know,
the r and b on it,
you know what I'm saying?
I'm a real singer,
you know,
I've been seeing it.
He said,
don't do that.
Just just sing the song because it's hip
hop.
And I said,
okay,
cool.
So I begrudgingly sung a song.
I'm thinking songs whack.
He's not gonna make it.
So I went off,
I did a bad movie.
I come back about six weeks,
eight weeks later,
that song is number one.
My boy goes like,
you remember that song you said wasn't
shit is number one in the country,
and then that's how I got into the
music.
So long story longer.
It's like,
yeah,
you can do all of the things and there's
a lot of actors and actresses that can.
You just need those opportunities.
Just like in life when your.
When your opportunity comes,
if you prepare for it now could jump
into it and grab it.
And what I was told was by my guy
brianne who does all of my music,
he found slow jams.
He found a goal that you found,
blame it on the alcohol.
He says you got to stop singing funny
shit and seeing a real record and once
you sing the real record and not say
it's you singing it,
now you got a better goal.
So now after all of those years,
the people that grew up with me was
doing standup or watch a date.
They're older and they're a young folks
is like
you'd kanye man,
just like how,
you know the guys now going into
michael,
so,
so as I get older,
you hope that you're blessed with
opportunities and you know,
the old saying,
but to sort of reinvent or reintroduce
yourself to people who may not know who
you are,
what's also guys like you have other
interests.
You have more than one interest.
You don't just want to be funny.
Yeah,
there's a lot going on in there.
It's,
it's a lot,
you know,
but like,
like we all are like comedians.
We got a lot of shit that we want to get
out.
And like I said,
being a comedian,
we had,
we,
we used to have.
It's getting,
it's getting crazier.
It's getting tough on us as far as you
know,
everything we say,
you know,
they want to come kill us.
I mean,
I did,
I did one,
I did jimmy fallon,
one seedinG the jimmy fallon in every
organization want to get me.
What did you say?
I was doing a joke,
uh,
of singing.
We were singing these funny songs about
who let the dogs out and so we took who
let the dogs out and put it in like a,
um,
like a,
like a vaudeville or show tune who let
the dogs or whatever it was.
Right.
But beginning of that I saw that ad lib,
like I was watching these dogs and they
were coming towards me and I was
wondering,
you know,
who let them out and there was a pit
bull there and you know,
you have to be careful because pit bulls
can be contentious,
you know.
And then I go into the song,
the pit bull community.
I was like jamie foxx,
session people shameless.
And then there was another thing where
jimmy fallon was doing,
was doing some type of,
uh,
he was saying what was going to be on
the next show.
And I was doing a bad version of
signing,
which I actually know how to sign if I
was doing a bad version of sign
language.
I know we'll talk more about it later,
you know,
all those types of different things.
But as I was doing it as a joke,
I didn't know that the person that he
was talking about happened to be deaf.
Oh no.
Oh my god.
And so then,
you know,
so it was just all of these things.
And I try to tell people,
I said,
hey,
listen,
we never mean anything bad.
We poke fun,
but we're not.
We don't mean anythIng bad,
but you can't just,
you can't,
you can't kill us.
I.
And because I got to keep doing what I
do,
you know?
So it's,
it's getting tougher.
Well,
it's just what we're talking about,
social,
about people
commenting on things that you can't read
the comments.
There's just too many people and people
are always looking for something to be
recreationally outraged at in the
comments and get that ass through the
comment,
comment and hit you right where you go
sometimes because damn,
this motherfucker's right.
It's good to though a little bit.
You went there right?
When they're actually right.
Like someone can say something
ridiculous about you and if you know
it's ridiculous,
it doesn't mean anything,
but if it's got a hint of truth.
But when somebody says something about
your teeth,
you,
you kind of look in the mirror.
I don't understand,
man.
I got like,
I'm fucked up.
I got.
But I got somebody hit me with the
donkey,
yo fucking donkey.
I was like,
ah,
yeah.
So,
you know.
But I tell people all the time,
don't read the comments.
That's the book comments,
because it will make you start to change
the way you do things.
If I read all the comments,
I never tell another joke.
Yeah,
if I read all the comments,
I'll never try another,
you know,
the,
I got a movie that we just a shot for
little or nothing called all star
weekend.
And the jokes are like all the way out
there,
you know,
and it's,
I got everybody in it,
you know,
and we're all taking.
We all play different characters.
Like I play a white racist,
white racist cop.
And how do you do that?
I'll show it to you.
I'll grab,
I'll grab this thing and show it to you.
But it's a robert downey jr.
He plays a mexican,
a gerard butler plays a russian who
loves gymnastics.
Uh,
benicia del toro plays is crazy tattoo
artist and we're all,
you know,
we're all doing our thing.
So it's like if you read the comments
that'll make you tuck that in,
but this is some brilliant and,
and it's,
it's,
it's a cool little thing to it.
It's called a all star weekend for a
reason.
It's about two guys.
One guy loves steph curry,
the other guy loves lebron james and all
they're trying to do is get to the all
star game and it's sorta like this whole
journey of running into all these
people.
So it's dope,
but it has some things where it's like,
ooh,
you know,
you can see there's going to be some,
some shit going on.
But robert downey jr,
just from tropic thunder,
think about that.
You could never do that anymore.
You can't blackface anymore.
You know what I'll say this,
people have to understand where it comes
from.
There are real people that did it really
mean you harm like outside of us.
I mean there's some real people who
really don't fucking like you.
Whatever you are,
whether you're black,
you're white,
you're straight,
gay,
whatever it is.
There's some people who really don't
with the entertainment and it's easy.
We're easy.
Targets were easy.
It's easy for you to jump on.
Robert downey jr or jamie five.
So joe,
because it's easy,
you know,
when it's real things,
which you know,
whether it's politics or whether it's
whatever.
A lot of times we,
we sorta,
we're not ready for that fight,
but it's easy to sort of pick the
comedian.
I called robert,
I said,
listen,
I need you to play a mexican.
He says,
dude,
here's the deal.
Sure.
Why not?
Fuck it.
Sure.
Of course you're mexican,
whatever.
But then he texts back and said,
I'm nervous to play the mexican.
I said,
well shit,
you played the black dude and you killed
that shit.
Which just all,
you know,
we to be able to do character.
What kind of blow back did he get from
playing the black dude?
None.
Because we finished before the wire too
though.
it was like,
what year is tropic thunder?
I feel like that was like 10 years ago.
It was awhile.
But,
but,
but here's the thing,
we fuck with robert downey jr.
Like that's our guy.
Like I did his birthday party and my
first joke was how dare you take all of
these roles from black people,
you know?
Anyway,
everybody's laughing.
So it sorta liked to entertain as man,
we,
we got to give us room.
You know what I'm saying?
Like to play any.
I'll show you when I got to take that
room.
You gotta take it.
You can't worry about.
I started chappelle somewhere.
It was like,
you know,
they would ask him about his jokes and
he was like,
yo man,
look,
you know,
people have said worse shit.
And I think it said something about
Donald Trump saying grab by the pussy or
some shit,
whatever.
But it was true.
It was like the oNe thing that you look
at what happened with politics this
year,
people sort of stripped away a lot of
things.
You know what I'm saying?
Regardless of what you believed in a
whatever person you voted for.
It was a lot of things that were sort of
addressed about like maybe we're playing
things a little too close,
like some of those politicians were
afraid to say what Donald Trump was
saying and they ended up being left in
the dust because people were like,
well,
he's,
he's got a point in the sense of we're
playing things a little too close.
So,
uh,
when you look at that as a comedian,
it's like,
wow,
that was,
that was good for me.
And it was good for me in a certain way
of.
First of all,
it is great jokes too.
It's like,
it does say,
are we becoming too fragile when it
comes to our race?
Like black folk?
Like I said,
yeah,
some people are racist and some people
are perceptionist know what that means.
Know the perception is the perception in
America was the white man.
Donald trump can be president.
The woman can't do it.
Perception doesn't mean that if you vote
for Donald Trump that you're racist.
I don't think everybody's here because
that was a big thing.
Sometimes this perception I'll,
I'll make,
I'll make it clear.
I do a joke in front of all black people
and I said,
black people are very interesting people
because we deal with racism and
perception ism.
I said,
because we're very nervous.
Flyers,
right?
We don't like to get home planes.
First thing we do when we get on the
plane,
we see who's flying this motherfucker.
We look in The cockpit.
If we look and see a black guy,
we will stop and go,
hey,
how long have you been flying?
But uh,
you got your hours with you.
And that was the perception and don't
let a woman sitting next to him.
Oh shit we good.
It could be a bright sunny day.
Is that how's the weather?
Or we're good.
And then as you're sitting in that seat,
anytime you hit a bump bump,
my brother,
we straight,
same situation.
You go in the cockpit,
you see that white guy with that salt
and pepper hair and those aviators and
it's forum hair like this and it's
storming outside.
Shit fly the shit through a hurricane.
So it's the perception that we have to
talk about some time.
Does that make sense?
Oh,
it definitely makes sense.
Yeah.
You know,
there's definitely that you don't like
the Donald Trump thinks funny.
Know who had it,
said it best.
Alonzo bowden,
you know,
alonzo.
No funny comedian,
he said he goes,
not all Donald Trump supporters are
racist,
but aLl racists are Donald Trump
supporters.
That he definitely awakened that side.
But I repeat,
I will,
but I will say this,
like I said,
the perception gets us all to know
because like my daughter,
it was interested in my oldest,
my oldest daughter,
like when,
when the,
uh,
when the election happened and when you
know,
the results came in,
dan,
I'm so mad I can't take it.
I said,
well,
what,
you were going to go march.
I said,
what did you all vote?
Not all of us,
but you know,
I said,
well,
you know,
you gotta get out there because their
perception was she had it in the bag.
You know what I'm saying?
So you gotta get out there and be,
you know,
whatever that is.
Yeah.
Whatever that is.
Indeed.
This is a weird times for everybody,
you know,
because I think social media is allowing
people to express themselves.
Everybody's expressed themselves and
perform them forming groups,
you know,
they're just like,
they're progressive or they're,
they're,
they're liberal or they're conservative
and this everybody has a voice is
everybody has a voice.
There's so much voices.
I'll say this,
maybe you can appreciate this because
we've,
we've lived,
were living in two worlds.
We live when it wasn't here and we live
in it's discretion.
Social media allows you not to have
discretion.
You're able to go in and type whatever
you want to say and that usually that's
what we pay attention to.
Discretion is this.
We're sitting at the dinner table and
yo,
I said something that you did like,
but the discretion was.
I'll address that later.
Right?
So now that you don't have any
discretion,
anybody's voice can be heard.
Not everybody.
How do you say it?
Not everybody has a point that we should
hook all of our wagons to.
What I noticed is that we will hook our
wagons to the most extreme point and
that may be only 2,500
people.
Like when my homies with him,
he said,
man,
you hear what they say,
man it,
but as soon as I said how many views did
it get?
80,000
views.
I says 8 million people in philly alone.
Why are you just listening to those
80,000
people?
So you sort of have to put balance in
the way you sort of sift through it.
Does that make sense?
It does make sense.
Yeah.
Well,
the way I tried to put it out to people,
if you're running into the room and
there's 100 people in that room,
what are the odds that one person is a
fucking idiot.
One hundred percent,
right?
Yeah.
One person.
It almost,
almost every room of a random group of
100 people and I'm being very,
very polite.
One person,
that means probably a few,
probably a few,
but let's go with one.
One out of 100.
So that means there's 3 million fucking
idiots in this country.
Just straight idiots.
Non unfixable idiots.
yeah.
so if you're going to read the comments,
you're opening yourself up to that.
If you're going to get your opinion
swayed by people who just want to just
want to see if they can affect you,
just want to see if they can fuck with
you and touch you.
Just see a big james to get you to
change the way you're dressing.
That's probably I don't like.
So I tell all of my artists and all my
friends don't change.
Don't read it because what happens is
everybody starts coloring inside the
lines and then nobody's dangerous
anymore.
Right?
Because you remember back in the day,
madonna,
dangerous point,
right?
I thought I'd come out naked just
dancing to the grant.
He's like,
it's all good.
You know what I'm saying?
So what I hope will want,
I always say,
just don't tuck your art in.
Don't tuck your art in for,
for the,
for the comments,
because we'll end up not having
anything.
Not having anything to celebrate.
That is.
That is good.
Like having something to celebrate.
Somebody did a song that was dope or
movie.
That was dope.
I got outside the box as opposed to what
we love celebrating,
which is the crazy shit.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
Well,
especially for comics because it's one
per.
If you do a crazy movie is a lot of
people involved.
Yeah.
If you're onstage you say something
fucked up.
It's just you.
Yeah.
I'm going back out.
So it's about to happen.
I'm gonna be passing out a whole bunch
of gift baskets because I'm going back
out and I,
you know,
like how much time did you take off?
I've never actually taken off because I
still do gigs.
Like I got a gig tomorrow,
st louis,
you know,
private gig,
whatever.
But,
but it's just,
you know,
like I know like as a comedian you gotta
live like I just can't jump out there
and just started talking or writing
jokes.
Like I've lived through some crazy shit
so I got to go out there and talk about
that.
You know,
had I not been hell because the one
Thing I hate is the one thing that's
tough for comedian is to become
successful because we talk from a shit
is fucked up point of View and I got to
have a little anger and I got to have a
little poke fun and if I become that,
what if I become what I poke fun at,
then I can't get it off.
That's why my house people come to my
house.
My daughter used to ask me this dad,
why is this room not?
There's nothing in it.
I said I dOn't want to complete the
house because it gives me a sense of
like,
I'm still trying to get on like I don't
ever want.
I don't put like all the pictures.
Nothing is perfect in my crib.
There's a curtain right now.
There's torn open in my bedroom,
you know like what?
What's going on with j?
Fox man,
what's going on?
Getting them checks when it was done and
I just said I just got to leave it like
that.
I keep my house a little sore that we
call it the dysfunctional mention.
I talk about this dysfunctional
management where there's always somebody
like,
like the other night there's odell
beckham in my house,
a battle dance and chris brown,
you know what I'm saying?
Like,
who does that?
You know what I'm saying?
I just,
just crazy shit happening at my house
all the time.
So I could,
I have something to link my,
you know,
hitch my wagon to.
So you will create chaos on purpose and
a little bit of.
I'll just leave it slight disarray.
I,
I don't,
I don't remove myself.
It,
I don't remember.
I don't get behind the gates behind the
gates of the worst shit behind the gates
behind the gates.
When you get behind the gates,
when you reach a certain point and
you're behind the gates,
you can't really see what I'm out.
I got to be out with the people.
I got to have people like I had a,
a bet party,
right?
3,000
people in my house counted jesus.
People at the gate,
you know,
trying to get in.
And as I looked through the party,
there's floyd mayweather all time.
Y'all.
What's up?
J.
Fox.
What's up,
baby?
I love you man,
you got to fight crime and jail,
you know.
so there's Florida is fat joe.
ThIs little kim is on stage performing
and then I look around and I see some of
the homies,
like the real guys that whatsapp fox,
I just nice party right here cause I
love it.
I'm like,
oh shit.
So it's all of these mixtures of people
that I can still touch,
hang out with people from my,
from my community.
Uh,
her name is bianca.
She's like the unofficial mayor in our,
in our cities,
old little white lady from Germany and
she's on the dance floor dancing with
snoop snoopy.
The snoopy is so good in the weird.
I don't know it,
it's crazy.
So I sort of keep it that way so I could
stay loose.
So when I go out I got,
I got shit that I could talk about from
the hood.
So you're still,
you still manage to stay a regular
person.
Got to.
But that's a hard thing for someone
who's achieved as much success as you
have.
that is not an easy balancing act to
stay normal because you must get
overwhelmed by requests and people just
wanting your time and wanted a hitch
hitch themselves to you and.
But you got to
look.
I think what helpS me is to see the
failures,
like doing a couple of movies that
don't,
you know what I'm saying?
Going through tsa.
They don't speak to you.
Your movie is out and then come over
there.
They don't even make eye contact with
you.
All right,
good.
Going through data movies.
So.
Or you just get the tsa goddamn fives.
What you doing baby?
What was that shit?
That shit dog.
I had to watch that shit on fire.
Stick my nigga.
Know what I'm saying?
Like oh.
So it's like you appreciate those which
keeps you regular,
keeps you humble.
And uh,
and you just got to sort of look at
other people and see how people in our
business when they do get behind the
gates,
you know,
you've seen comics that get that
thousand mile stare and don't want.
I don't mean funny no more.
Yeah.
I want you to be funny more.
That's how you came up.
I want to be sexy now.
You know what I'm saying?
They all fall into the sexy,
you know?
Nah.
I don't want to say funny.
It keep the teeth gooby,
keeping my head looking goofy hair at
whatever it is because that's what I
draw upon when I go out because people
can sense it,
don't you think?
Oh yeah,
yeah.
I think stand up is kind of in some ways
it's a like a mind meld or a massive
gnosis like gear connecting with the
audience and if there's anything false
about what you're thinking or what
you're saying,
some of them at least can feel it.
SometImes all of them,
but some of them can feel it and it'll
fuck with the energy of the room,
but if you're in the groove,
you're really being yourself.
That's why when you see dave onstage,
one of the things about chappelle is
that he's always himself.
He can just be himself and so you relax
as an audience member and slide right
into his mind and he takes you on a
journey because he's himself.
He's not,
he's not.
He's not dIsconnected by fame and
celebrity and that way he was cheating.
Yes.
How he passed up.
All that money just went to africa,
just settled in and then came back and
didn't do any scheduled gigs for years.
He would show up with a speaker and set
up a speaker in a park in seattle and
just gather a crowd around and start
doing standup.
Yeah,
my seat.
But that's what I'm saying.
It's like,
how do you find that?
He figured it out how he did it?
Well,
I agree with that because like I said,
if you success can sometimes be our,
our coffin,
especially when you're,
like I said when you're,
when you're a comic,
even all the way down to the way I
handled like,
like uh,
like social media is interested in me
just sort of brand new on it and what
people view.
LIke I was a,
and this is sort of off off subject,
but I was just talking about how people
view you.
I went to the gas station and I put on
these sheets and then I took a picture
of him.
I thought it was cool.
I was at needed some pickup,
some,
you know,
$14 shit with her now put it on.
I took a picture with him and my
instagram blew up.
Like,
oh shit,
what's this?
I to come.
It's like,
man,
when you get the shades.
And there was a ferragamos gucci's what
I'm saying like,
what are those dollar?
Hey,
let me get added fire.
I was like,
wow,
it's just gas station shades.
But everybody thought they was,
you know,
something else.
And I was like,
nah,
I don't want that.
I don't want them to think that.
I don't want them to think that I spent
$2,000
because that's,
we always lose our fucking shades
anyway.
Right.
So I actually hit my boy davao and uh,
dave schottenstein,
I said,
listen,
I want to do a eyeglass,
like,
whoa,
what are you going to do?
You want to go?
I said,
no,
I want to do an eyeglass that costs less
than $30.
I said,
but what we're gonna do is we're going
to go through each frame and make sure
each frame is tight,
like the dope,
like amazing.
Because I told them the story about
being at the gas station and they were
liKe,
wow,
I think that's a good idea.
So we ended up doing this whole line.
I went through all 200 frames and we
did.
This line's a,
it's called a revolt,
right?
And everybody thought that it was
something else.
30 bucks,
$30 shiFts and now even dot lo,
bella thorne and all these other people
are wearing the shades.
BeCause what we noticed when we did do
that,
people embrace it a little more because
we did a commercial that was that we
almost made that mistake where we get
clothes on and we tell people how much
the clothes cost and people got turned
off because the jeans were like $400.
Jacket was 2000.
They were like,
what the fuck?
And I'm like,
no.
What we were trying to say was,
although these closing costs,
it's our glasses only cost 30 bucks.
So that story In itself,
I take that and run with that and say
like,
I'm not the guy buying the high end,
you know stuff.
I want to keep it sorta cool.
Regular,
you know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
Does that make sense?
it does.
Yeah.
I know it really rich dude who drives a
pickup truck.
He's rich as fuck and he just likes to
drive around in a shitty old toyota
pickup truck.
He likes it.
And why you do that?
Because he wants to feel normal,
feel normal,
feel grimy.
You want to feel normal.
He doesn't wash his hands sometimes.
Get dirt under his fingernails.
pretends he's a farmer and combined a
whole fucking world.
People are weird like that.
But we have to balance both because I.
Because,
because you know,
you know,
beIng,
being,
you know,
being urban,
I got to step out there and shine
sometimes too.
I'm a boy has,
you know,
we,
we get out there and we show a little
bit of the suCcess,
you know what I'm saying?
Just to let people know we're still
doing our thing.
The expression being urban that
happened.
How did it become urban?
Wait,
what year was that?
Joking like I'm blaCk.
I tell people all the time,
I'm going to nicc h nica if I lose,
if I lose,
if I lose me in that,
then I,
I got to have that.
You know what I'm saying?
Oh god,
yeah,
I got it.
Yeah,
no,
I got it.
You got to have everything.
It's fun to write.
Yeah,
it's fun too.
but I gotta I gotta have that part.
I got to have always had that sorta like
a can't leave.
Can't leave where I came from because
that's what they try to snatch from me.
That's why we did.
We did the television show.
Chris spencer in a buddy lewis wrote
this,
wrote this incredible script called
white famous and white famous was about
a comedian who's trying to become
mainstream without losing his,
you know,
his black audience,
which is all these.
All of us.
We go through that,
you know,
because the minute you started doing
the,
you know,
the sort of soft movies and brother man,
you don't cuss no more motherfuckers
you cussing.
You know,
I think the problem with shining is when
it defines you problem when,
when you just.
Everything is flat like floyd mayweather
in a way.
It's part of his persona as part of why
people root against him.
Like ford is a genius and he my printing
not just a genius boxing,
he's the greatest defensive boxer,
my opinion of all time,
but also a genius in that he figured out
a way where he has this style that's not
appealing to a lot of people,
but what is appealing is people want to
see him get his ass kicked and it never
fucking happened.
Listen,
in
floyd's the hmi floyd comes by the house
man and I don't want to put everything
out there that he does.
He's super,
super competItive.
That's what's amazing.
But he also understands that yo,
j fox,
I understanding what's going on.
Your alternate.
They,
they,
they want me to follow j fox,
but that's what keeps me competitive all
the time.
Easy work,
light work.
So he would sit at my crib and speak for
like hours about the business of it,
trying to turn these boxers.
Mine's on like,
yo,
get your money,
know what I'm saying?
Don't get your money,
get your business,
get on.
And then he talks about just what you
said.
He says,
I know the reason that I fight oscar de
la hoya on cinco de mayo is because they
want to see the va.
He,
he,
he carved out a niche for
being the,
the,
the charismatic villain.
does that make sense?
Yeah.
And he wasn't in the beginning.
he wasn't,
he,
he was pretty boy floyd mayweather here.
And then he became money mayweather.
Yeah.
But had he stayed pretty boy.
Who the fuck does that mean?
He might've been like sugar shane mosley
or something,
but not really because shane had lost to
a few guys like what floyd did better
than anybody is not get hit.
Yeah.
He's been here like six times.
Right?
Right.
Like really hard.
Like six times.
And zap judy?
Yeah.
Zeb judo.
Uh,
his defining fight was the morale is
fight when he fought morales.
God bless was amazing in that he also
said that that hit the sugar.
Shane hit him and he'll tell you.
Said that hit when sugar,
shane touched him.
He said that really,
as she said,
shook me.
Said,
well Jeff Fox,
shit,
I'll kill him.
J fox,
I got to kill me.
He said,
that's why I dug in and you see the
energy.
You see the end of the round and end
around.
He did turn it,
but he's.
He got rocked In that fight.
That was one of the few moments where he
really got caught by a world class
fighter.
Yeah.
Got caught cleaned twice,
so it'll be interesting.
This next fight coming up.
Well,
connor's not that level of boxer.
You know someone.
I forget who it was.
It said it.
I think it might've been a daily.
Yeah,
but someone was saying that he's got to.
I was patent [inaudible] saying that he
has to almost cheat within the rules and
I think he's got to like fight in the
clinic.
She's got to like dirty box.
He's got to figure out a way to tie him
up and manipulate them and move his body
around.
He's got to figure out A way to be good
defensively to and he's got a hurt them.
Those would all be like high,
high risk,
low yield possibilities.
It's the way I described it.
If you,
how would you expect the greatest figure
skater in the world to do playing hockey
against wayne gretzky high?
It's not the same thing.
What is fucking exciting,
greatest freak show ever?
He says the greatest freak show ever.
Um,
I'm waiting for that fight more than
canelo alvarez versus gennady golovkin.
Even though that fight is a legitimate
fight.
Fight but can't because it's going to be
some crazy shit.
Some crazy shit.
He's gonna be so crazy.
Well,
also there's the mindfuck factor.
He's the connor's the only guy that
floyd's ever fought that can look at
them and go,
if this was a real fight,
you'd be fucking dead.
Oh knows he knows it.
EveRybody else floyd's been able to fuck
up.
He fucks up all of them,
you know,
like,
do you ever see that video with him and
robert carero?
Right before they fought,
they had this,
um,
this thing where they were doing photo
shoots and they to do a stereo.
Is it?
Who's this roBert that goes?
Guerrero is a fighter that floyd for
maybe four or five,
five years ago,
and he just worked for 12 rounds.
Spirit the shit out,
but he's standing right in front of
them.
He said,
you ain't gonna do shit.
He's like,
you're easy work.
You're easy work.
He goes,
he goes,
I'm just gonna stack.
It goes,
no one has to get involved.
You're not going to do shit.
He goes,
we'll get right close to each other.
You're not going to do shit.
You're easy work.
And you could see the dude was just
like,
oh no.
Like he knew.
He knew that floyd was right,
right?
Well,
when connor looks at him and goes,
if this is a real fight,
I'd fucking kill you.
I'll do your boxing thing.
It's a real fight.
I'll kill you.
Oh yeah,
he's right.
He's right.
Like,
if you could say,
oh,
this how we'll do some mma.
He said it a couple times.
Next fight will do mma.
He's not doing floyd floyd thing float
is smart.
yeah.
So he looked.
He's got him on his,
his,
his play and feel.
So it's almost like you start to like.
I know,
but people started to go like as floyd
nervous.
I said,
I don't know,
but I tell you this,
he's definitely allowing this guy to
play through in that fight is becoming
bigger,
bigger.
So it's like it's going to be,
it's going to be great.
And the one thing float would always
tell me though,
he said j fox.
He said the one thing they not ready for
it,
it's the lights.
I said,
what you mean?
He said the lights,
when the lights are that bright and you
look out and you see all,
you see denzel,
you see all these.
That's a different.
That's a different thing because it was
tough.
I don't know if it was hatton.
I think we're talking about hat and
sending the lights,
man.
He said that's the one thing I've been
fighting j five and fighting under the
license.
I was like this.
So it's going to be interesting.
Yeah.
This is going to be interesting me
crazy,
but connor fights under the lights too.
We just never boxed anybody like that.
That's going to be a totally alien
thing.
When he gets into that ring and he's got
shoes on and he fills those big ass
gloves on his hands and then it looks on
the other side.
He sees floyd is moving around and
getting ready.
He's got.
There's going to be a shit.
It's going to be something in there.
It's going to be everything except me
fucking everything.
Because you think about it.
They both.
I mean they got us.
They got us.
I'm going to that motherfucker.
I'm going early.
Oh,
press conferences were amazing.
Yeah.
I'm already booked.
I was booked in dc that nIght in
advance.
I saw already sold out two shows that
night.
I couldn't.
I couldn't cancel and you can't come.
No,
I can't come.
I'm not going to be there.
I'm not going to work at either.
They wanted me to do something for it.
I couldn't loan.
Can't even do it.
That's going to be the.
I gotta figure out a way to see it.
Until not know what happened is normally
watch it.
I'm going to have to figure out a way.
I hope the audience would be nice and
not telling me it's probably going to be
people watching it on their phone while
the show's going on.
Like I guarantee you if someone gets
knocked down,
you're going to hear from the audience
what joke was.
Yeah,
what happened is great Man.
Great man.
it's gonna be interesting.
Listen man.
yEah,
there you go.
From here,
I don't know where we were.
That's where we started.
Where do we go from here?
We'll just keep moving and keep moving.
You're obviously enjoying yourself.
You're.
I'm having.
I'm having a good time for a super
successful guy.
You seem completely balanced today.
There are,
there are things that you just cannot
get away from that you know,
you hide right behind.
But for the most part I did some smart
stuff.
Moving my,
my whole family lives with me so I had
to worry about,
you know,
my,
my father and my mom lived with me.
Oh that's great.
Yeah.
And I was adopted seven months,
so,
you know,
and my mom,
me and my mom and my biological mom,
you know,
or crafting our relationship now in the,
in the latter stages of her life.
So,
you know,
that's,
but I didn't want,
but I didn't want no bullshit outside of
that,
you know,
where someone is,
is,
is sitting somewhere watching me from a
distance,
you know,
that,
so mom comes in and they've been
divorced for almost 30 years.
It was crazy.
So thEy live in the same,
same under the same roof.
It's hilarious.
That's a whole nother show.
Wow.
And uh,
he's still dates,
you know what I'm saying?
He's still getting it in and be over
there.
And then she'll float over to his side
of the house.
It'd be like,
let's see the girl,
hey,
how are you?
How are you?
Hi george.
This is who is this?
You know,
she's getting somebody.
I just want to get something out the
refrigerator,
some spoils,
stuff that does kind of intense.
And then you hear that on my door,
ms.my
mom and my pops.
Uh,
could you tell her not to come on my
side of the house?
Shit,
I'm like man,
I'm parents,
you know,
so,
but it's certain things that I got to
figure out your happiness and the only
way you figure out your happiness,
you got to try to see or foresee what's
going to be the problem.
So I get my family close to me.
So whatever problem we got to work out,
we work that shit out right here.
Get my mom and my,
and my and my sisters and my and my
daughter's close to me.
So they see daddy going to work.
Like there's still some work shit.
It's like,
no,
we just not on the red card.
It's not just red carpet everyday,
you know,
I gotta get up,
I gotta go,
I gotta talk shit.
I got to kiss a little ass here.
I gotta I gotta do a whole lot of shit
in order to keep this thing going.
So you try to,
you know,
in life you try to see what,
try to foresee what's going to happen.
It still going to be something.
So it's always gonna be something just
outlandish and uh,
but uh,
you,
you try to get,
get in front of it.
That's an interesting way to handle it
though,
to bring everybody close to bring your
whole family and your house.
Yeah.
And not everybody can do that,
you know,
because you know,
it's like,
you know,
me growing up as an only child,
I liked having people around.
I can't be by myself.
That's why I always would throw parties.
I can,
I would kidnap people like come to my
house.
Why you got to leave man.
Chris,
chris man.
Just say,
man,
I got a real fluid mid state New York
because I just wanted people right now
having my family around you.
You got to do.
But not like I said,
not everybody can do it.
[inaudible] it,
it,
it's,
it's interesting.
Like my father who has a great story,
my stepfather has a great story.
You know,
he was on drugs or,
or at had a situation about what drug
bout with crack.
Ended up going to jail.
I wrote him one letter.
I said,
you get out,
you know,
I save your life because I didn't like
writing letters to people in jail and
like going visiting people in jail.
He gets out.
This is around just before nine slash
11.
And then my stepfather was incredible in
my life because he taught me how to play
tennis.
So back in the seventies,
in the,
in the eighties,
he was like playing tennis.
I was like,
wow,
I've never seen a black dude play
tennis.
He said,
you got to learn some people like yanik
noah,
elina stasi beyond board,
vitos gerulaitis.
Those were like heroes of mine.
So he taught me how to play play tennis.
So when he gets out,
he gets out of jail and make sure
everything is cool.
I take him to the us open.
And so there is me and my pops watching
venus when he's crying.
I'm like,
yeah,
dad,
you know this,
this is how we got to live.
This is what,
this is what we need to do.
So he watches venus play and then a
couple of days after that,
it was nine slash 11.
Uh,
but you know,
he stayed with me,
he's been with me since then,
you know,
it early on I would just go by and check
the drawers,
make sure there's no paraphernalia,
no wrong shit,
smoke your weed.
It,
don't do no more than that.
And we've been cool since then,
you know,
and it saved a lot of money in rehab,
you know what I'm saying?
So I'm just right there and hands on.
But uh,
well sometimes people just being
surrounded by loved ones is enough to
keep them from doing anything stupid.
Yeah,
it can,
it can.
And it was,
it was bumpy at first,
won't go into it because he wrote a
little book and talked about it.
It was bumpy at first because when he
first got out I did some shit for him.
Got him,
got him,
got him a car,
whatever.
He relapsed this car,
gone.
He's back in,
you know.
So it was a couple little things that we
had to work out,
but now you know,
to see him now like,
you know,
like uh,
we go to these different events or
whatever like that.
He,
his whole wall,
he old school,
he don't,
he don't do this,
you know.
Then he got the actual photos.
He goes,
he goes to develop the,
like I made a little film so he put the
film in to develop the field,
see it,
and they put the field and he got a
whole wall and everybody's needs met,
you know,
all of his heroes.
And so like I said,
you know,
I try to try to look,
uh,
try to be ahead of the curve when it
comes to the fucked up shit.
What about like where your creative time
when you have 20 people living with you,
did you get,
do you ever feel boxed in?
Nah,
that's,
you know,
like I know the best way to create us
and have people around because I could
try that joke out on them and they don't
know I'm doing that job,
you know what I'm saying?
I could try this idea,
see how they respond because your family
gonna give you the real giving me that
as terrible.
See how you made it.
That's what I'm saying.
So you always got to me having people
around to tell you the truth,
you know,
like everybody in my family,
they tell me it's true for basil,
sleepless.
I should've just stayed sleep as that.
Oh shit really is fucked up.
Yeah.
So it's like,
you know,
having that allows me to create.
And then I have my own little space
where I go,
okay,
let me get this now let me.
They responded to that.
Now let me put this together over here
in a little space.
So you have like a little sanctuary.
I got a little studio that I,
that I set up where I go in there and do
all that shit,
you know?
But it helps.
Well listen man,
I know you gotta get the fuck out of
here.
You only here for an hour,
right?
Yeah,
it's been great dude.
Listen,
you are,
you're an amazing person and I'm very,
I'm very honored to have you on here
because you're one of the very few
people that I know that has this a well
rounded life,
but also it's very balanced.
Like you've had amazing success and all
these different things,
but you're as normal and approachable as
anybody I know when it come to you,
you know,
I got to be why you?
Because you are a speaker of truth and
we ain't seen each other in a while.
But the one thIng about your opinion is
always going to be truthful.
So you know,
as us coming from a different time,
there's certain people that we want to
have the real truth come from you.
Rock,
chappelle,
all these guys.
So we came up.
So when we're doing our art and when
we're doing whatever we do,
it's always going to be those people
that,
you know rock with you,
but you want to get the people who have
a really artistic,
real opinion.
Does that make sense?
I know.
And if you hear them say y'all kind of
fuck with that now.
Okay,
I got that.
If jr says that's cool,
then I know.
And I said,
why?
Why do you say that?
Because that motherfucker tell you,
he'll tell you that that shit's whack.
You know what I'm saying?
And then it whoop your ass.
So you gotta be,
you know,
you gotta be on point with this because
I know when I run into those guys like
you,
you want to have
that favor.
does that make sense?
I know exactly what you're saying
because you got to hold yourself to,
you got people in your mind right now.
Then when you're doing your thing that,
you know,
if everybody's yelling like,
oh,
we love you,
but if that person say maybe this or
maybe that you go,
okay,
yeah,
you know what I'm saying?
You people who are going to be 100
percent real.
So there you go.
You're a bad motherfucker.
Jamie foxx.
Thank you brother.
You are tonight.
All right.
And uh,
they told me to say prepaid revo get.
How do you get those riverboat?
You lose your clothes.
You never lose your glasses,
man.
And it's all of them at 29,
95.
Now you go,
there you go.
ladies and gentlemen,
please.